- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is use a graphing calculator
to answer some questions
dealing with binomial random variables
and this is useful because if
you're taking the AP Stats,
the Advanced Placement Statistics test,
you are allowed to use
a graphing calculator
and so this could actually
save you significant time.
So it says here I have a 0.35 probability
of making a free throw.
What is the probability of making
four out of seven free throws?
Well this is a classic binomial
random variable question.
If we said the binomial random variable x
is equal to number of made
free throws from seven,
I can say seven trials or seven shots,
seven trials with
the probability of success
is equal to 0.35 for each free throw.
So really this question amounts
to what is the probability
that my binomial random
variable x is equal to four?
Now what we're going to see is
we can use a function on our TI-84,
not named binomc,
or binompdf, I should say,
binompdf which is short
for binomial probability
distribution function,
and what you're going to want to do here
is use three arguments.
So the first one is the number of trials.
So in this case, it is seven,
and if you're doing it on
the free response section
of the AP test, you
should make it very clear
that that right over there is your n,
the graders will actually look for that
to make sure that you're not
just guessing what goes where.
So you would say that is my n
and then you would say
your probability, 0.35,
and once again if you're taking the test,
you should mark that.
That is your p.
And then last but not least,
what is the probability
that a binomial variable
when you're taking seven
trials with a probability
of success of each of them being 0.35
that you have exactly four successes.
So now lets get our calculator out
and actually do that.
Alright, so now we have our
graphing calculator out.
So there's a couple of ways to input this.
You could just type it in
directly, that could take time.
You could do second in this
little blue distribution here.
So there you have it.
In order to get to the function,
you could either scroll down
or you could scroll up to
get to the bottom of the list
and you see it right over here, binompdf.
You could do alphaA to
go there really fast
or you could just scroll
up here, click enter,
and then, you have the number of trials
that you want to deal with.
Well we're gonna take seven trials,
the probability of success
in each trial is 0.35,
and then my x value,
well I wanna find the probability
that my binomial random
variable is equal to four,
four successes out of the trials.
And now let me go to paste
and this is actually
going to type in exactly
what we had before.
Notice this is the exact same thing.
So I have seven trials,
p is equals to 0.35,
and I wanna know the probability of having
exactly four successes,
and then I just click enter
and I get, there you go, 0.14.
So this is equal to
approximately 0.14.
Now based on the same
binomial random variable,
if we're then asked
what is the probability
of making less than five free throws?
So we could say this is the probability
that x is less than five
or we could say this is the probability
that x is less than or equal to four,
and the reason why I write it this way
is because using it this way
you can now use the binomial cumulative
distribution function on my calculator.
So if I just type in binom,
and once again, I'm
gonna seven of binomcdf,
I should say, cumulative
distribution function
and I'm gonna take seven trials
and the probability of
success in each trial is 0.35
and now when I type in four here,
it doesn't mean what is the probability
that I make exactly four free throws,
it is the probability
that I make zero, one,
two, three, or four free throws.
So all of the possible outcomes
of my binomial random variable up to
and including this value right over here.
So let me get that,
let me get my calculator back,
so once again, I can go
to second, distribution,
I'll scroll up to go to
the bottom of the list
and here you see it,
binomial cumulative distribution function.
So let me go there, click enter.
And once again, seven trials,
my p is 0.35,
and my x value is four,
but now this is not going to
be giving me the probability
that my binomial random
variable equals four,
this is going to give me the probability
that I get any value up
to and including four.
So this should be a higher probability.
And there you have it,
it is approximately 0.94.
So this is approximately 0.94.
So hopefully you found that helpful.
These calculators can be very useful
especially on something
like an AP Stats exam.